i got cornered by three of my sixth
grade students at lunch today and they
came up to me all excited they were like
miss callings callings what's your
sexuality
i said why do you need to know that
right now
um and they were like oh i don't know i
just think you'd be like a super fun
like
buyer pan person
and i said well i don't really know how
much i'm allowed to talk about this to
students but
um
does looking at my shoelaces help and
these kids just flipped out they were so
excited so either the story didn't
happen
which is possible
or the story did happen in which case i
really questioning both the teaching
tactics of the school and the parenting
tactics of the kids
you run up to people and you ask them
about their sexuality and sexual
orientation and then as a teacher you're
subtly signaling to your students your
gender and sexual identity via shoelaces
this is also important